you
mr. president mr. Provost mr.
president-elect Madam Secretary masters
Dean's colleagues friends families and
most of all women and men of the class
of 2013 welcome
welcome to this day I now call on the
university chaplain please rise
my sisters and my brothers I invite you
to join me in prayer almighty and loving
God in the majesty of this life moment
we your beloved children of different
colors Creed's generations stories and
tongues are gathered in this place as
one human family united in jubilant
celebration we are filled with gratitude
for our families friends teachers and
guides their arms have sheltered us
their shoulders have boosted us and
today their hearts sore for us eternal
God it is you who calls us to our full
humanity as we celebrate our
accomplishments we are humbled and
overwhelmed by what lies ahead let us
continue to caress the beauty of your
creation and may our souls no true
delight as we awaken to the wonder of
our own unfolding lives through the
unity of mind and spirit hold us ever
close as we seek to live in your world
wisely in the steadfast pursuit of your
light and your truth and for this we say
amen
a reading from psalm 43 send forth your
light and your truth they will lead me
they will bring me to your holy mountain
to your dwelling place that I may come
to the altar of God God my delight my
joy that I may praise you with the harp
oh god my god a reading from the book of
Matthew you are the light of the world a
city built on a hill cannot be hid no
one after lighting a lamp puts it under
the bushel basket but on the lamp stand
and it gives light to all in the house
in the same way let your light shine
before others so that they may see your
good works and give glory to your father
in heaven
a reading from the Quran God is the
light of the heavens and earth the
likeness of his light is that of a niche
in which there is a lamp the lamp is in
a glass the glass is as it were a
brilliant star lit from a blessed tree
and olive neither of the East nor of the
West whose oil seems to glow even though
no fire has touched it light upon light
God guides whom He wills to his light
God makes parables for humanity and God
has knowledge of everything
you
well that was awfully quick weren't we
just meeting here in your freshman year
do you recall our first time together in
Woolsey Hall I spoke to you about time
how time would race along with you in
these four years and of the Maya
calendar which would reach its so-called
end date during the winter vacation of
your senior year and I assured you at
the time the time would roll along and
now like the Maya calendar you two are
entering a new era on this occasion
baccalaureate it is customary for the
president to deliver a baccalaureate
address and for the Dean of yelp college
to offer a few readings so make
yourselves comfortable for some readings
I've chosen to share with you in your
daily travels at Yale you walk through
this building where we are today Woolsey
Hall on a regular basis some of you have
walked through the Rotunda dozens of
times a week you think of this space as
Commons or as the grand concert hall
that surrounds us now but what is this
building it's a war memorial and this is
once again a week before memorial day
when we think of and honor those who
have died in their nation's service from
lexington massachusetts to afghanistan
but the commemoration in may and the
concept of the idea in May took place
after the Civil War when more Americans
died than in all the other wars in which
US soldiers have fought the names of
Yale soldiers Union and Confederate
north and south are inscribed just
outside this hall
150 years ago in 1863 this nation was in
the midst of that war friends and
classmates had taken up arms against one
another by the end of the war and after
700,000 yes nearly three-quarters of a
million soldiers had died President
Lincoln closed his second inaugural
address in this way with malice toward
none with charity for all with firmness
in the right as God gives us to see the
right let us strive on to finish the
work we are in to bind up the nation's
wounds to care for him who shall have
borne the battle and his widow and his
orphan to do all which may achieve and
cherish a just and lasting peace among
ourselves and with all nations a just
and lasting peace Yale students by and
large they were young men from New
England in those years would have read
those words in a local newspaper perhaps
reading the text aloud to one another
those students knew the rent in the
National fabric the broken bones of the
united states that had not yet begun to
knit together we continue to strive for
healing now nearly 150 years later in
both national and international respects
lincoln calls for healing in this formal
speech to his countrymen to care for him
for his widow his orphan as part of its
continuing series about the
sesquicentennial of the Civil War the
New York Times has been running a series
of on the topic and they featured the
short life of a foot soldier killed at
Gettysburg in 1863 and whose orphaned
children became symbols of the wars
sacrifice of the abandoned and wounded
who would need care and comfort and
friendship The Times has given the
fallen soldier a new life in a story of
hardscrabble farming wailing and battle
compellingly revealed in his letters to
his wife where one learns that they were
one another's best friends in the short
lines of his last letter home he found a
way to express the depth of his love for
his friend if I ever live to get home
you will not complain of being lonesome
again or of sleeping cold for I will lay
as close to you as the bark to a tree
Amos Humiston days before the Battle of
Gettysburg 1863 you arrived here as
strangers remember once again that
freshmen assembly when President Levin
and I welcomed you you looked around
this vast Hall wondering what your path
would be and who you would know and love
as you make your plans to leave you
leave as friends some of you have been
my own friends and it's been my great
joy to know so many of you you 2013 are
the first class who steps I have watched
from bulldog days to today here's what
happens to you yell undergraduates you
change you acquire new knowledge much of
it useful some of it quirky you learn
how to ask better questions a generation
or two learn to do so there were
children's encyclopedia known as the
book of knowledge perhaps the addition
of 1936 from which this prose poem by a
Yale faculty member is conceived whose
black and white cracked spines sat on a
shelf in my family home the reading for
long winters stay with me for 17
questions as I take you to from the book
of knowledge by Cynthia Zarin one what
makes a fairy ring fairy rings are made
of a kind of fungus to why does damp air
make us ill
damp air is often cold air and the cold
has usually been blamed for making us
ill though many facts prove that it is
not blameworthy at all three why does a
dog go round and round before it lies
down the answer to this question lies in
another question what is a dog for can
our brains ever fill up the poet
browning says there is no end to
learning 5 why does a tuning fork sound
louder when it touches would the sound
from a tuning fork like the light from a
candle flows out in all directions 6 why
are some things poisonous we could only
answer this question completely and
fully if we knew all there is to know
about life 7 why can we hear better when
we shut our eyes this question is partly
true and partly not true can an animal
think eight there is no doubt an animal
can think and that it can remember 9 do
animals feel pain as we do that is not a
question that can be answered directly
10 why do we not growl like animals when
we are hungry a hungry man is an angry
man 11 why have leaves different shapes
the great idea which we can apply to
every fact about living creatures is
that these facts usually have uses 12
why do the leaves of the aspen always
shake the shaking of the leaves has the
same effect as if the trees were Fanning
themselves 13 why does oil make a wheel
go round more easily it all depends on
where the oil is put
14 why do we see the stars only at night
the stars are shining all the time
sending light to earth but more than
this is needed for us to see 15 is an
atom living it is almost a living thing
16 can country people see writ small
better than townspeople if country folk
use their eyes mainly at distances their
vision will be keenest at distances 17
why does a lump rise in my throat when I
cry it is the place of speech which is
the most marvelous thing finally it is a
yale college tradition to read a passage
by john milton on this occasion you know
the story i think there were these two
young 20-somethings maybe even teenagers
in a garden they were in a perfect place
and they knew that they also knew that
there was a world beyond and they
couldn't help but want to know about it
yes as in the Zarin poem there was
always a thirst for knowledge and then
you remember that in the garden there
was this wardrobe malfunction like you
and as you may particularly feel on
Monday afternoon or tuesday morning
their departure seemed to them sudden
unwarranted abrupt inevitable from
Paradise Lost by John Milton 1667 some
natural tears they dropped but wiped
them soon the world was all before them
where to choose their place of rest and
Providence their guide they hand in hand
with wandering steps and slow through
Eden
took their solitary way congratulations
class of 2013
you
good afternoon I want to begin by
welcoming all the parents relatives and
friends of our graduates to you parents
especially I want to say that I know
just how you feel Jane and I have had
the good fortune of watching all four of
our children graduate from college and
we know the pride and the pleasure that
you are experiencing and the many
memories that such an occasion conjures
up and I also know that what you would
really like to do right now is to stand
up and join those of us on stage in
offering warm congratulations to the
yale college class of 2013
and now I would like to ask the class of
2013 in turn to reflect for one moment
on how you came to reach this milestone
during that moment of reflection one of
the things that may have occurred to you
is that there are many people here today
your parents siblings relatives and
friends whose support and encouragement
made your achievements here possible I
bet you'd like to rise and show them
your appreciation
we leave together you leave yale college
after four years i leave the yale
presidency after twenty I find myself
thinking about the words of a grateful
dead song written in 1970 the year I
came to graduate school at Yale it's
been a long trip but for all of us more
wonderful than strange each of you has
had the opportunity to learn from
teachers who are among the world's most
brilliant scholars and to grow in the
company of some of the most exceptional
young adults to be found anywhere your
classmates you've had access to
extraordinary research laboratories
libraries museums and musical and
dramatic performances you've lived in
for years for four years in an
environment of high energy and high
achievement in the classroom and the
newsroom on the stage and the athletic
field in the concert hall and the art
studio in community service and in
political debate in the course of all
this activity you have come to know
yourselves more completely these
pleasures now give way to a new set of
challenges and opportunities as you
explore the world that is all before you
some of you know exactly what you want
to do in the years ahead whether it is
medicine the law the military starting a
company or this year in particular
playing professional hockey
congratulations we wish you every
success as for the rest of us who are
not so sure I feel for myself I feel
myself for the first time in 20 years of
baccalaureate addresses in true
communion with you you and I are going
to need time to figure out what's next
time to consider where our true passions
lie and how we might give them the
fullest expression it's not an easy
world out there we are still suffering
from the effects of the most severe
recession since the Great Depression and
the American political system wants a
global model of effective bipartisan
governance has become so polarized that
it is nearly paralyzed it seems
astonishing but this spring in the
aftermath of a mass murder at an
elementary school just 25 miles from
here the US Congress could not manage to
restore even the most moderate
restrictions on the sale of assault
weapons to private citizens and gun
control is just one of many critical
issues on which this nation appears to
be at impasse how about ensuring an
adequate K through 12 education for all
Americans
how about repairing our congested
highways deteriorating bridges
substandard airports and obsolete
passenger rail service how about
supporting scientific advance and
innovation the innovation that flows
from it how about resetting our
expectations about entitlements and how
about concerted action to mitigate the
severe economic and ecological
consequences of global warming
right now you might be you might not be
thinking first and foremost about these
issues you quite properly may be
thinking instead about where you will
find an apartment whether you will find
a job and if you already have one
whether you will like it you may also be
thinking about whether and when to apply
to graduate or professional school and
more generally about how these near term
choices might help you build a life that
is personally and professionally
fulfilling because Yale has encouraged
you to think this way you may also be
contemplating how the lives you are
starting to create might make a
difference to others to your families
and your communities and how you might
be of service as so many of you have
been as students to causes larger than
your own personal fulfillment I am
thinking about my next steps to and just
like you I'm hoping to find work that is
personally and professionally fulfilling
and that makes a difference in the lives
of others uncertainty about these
matters is a source of anxiety for us
all for you and for me but I think we're
up to it you have overcome a lot of
challenges as you've worked your way
through Yale and so if I there's plenty
of upside ahead at what we economists
call the micro level the immediate
personal and professional spheres that
we occupy but what about the macro level
what about the big picture issues that
lately have been so inadequately
addressed by our political processes
these may not be at the center of your
current plans but let me suggest that
there's plenty of opportunity here too
in my explanation I will focus
principally on the United States but
every country in the world faces similar
questions about education infrastructure
innovation and tie
elements and climate change the answers
to these questions are going to have a
huge impact on your personal and
professional lives affecting your
incomes your security your health and
your well-being your involvement with
these issues can make a difference
consider K through 12 education for more
than a century American primary and
secondary education was the envy of the
world producing the world's most
literate labor force and creating a huge
competitive advantage for the United
States as North America and Europe
industrialized today on the most widely
used international test of comparative
achievement the performance of
fifteen-year-old Americans ranks 14th
and reading 17th and science and 25th in
math among 34 OECD countries and almost
all of these 34 OECD countries are far
below Shanghai Singapore and Hong Kong
on all three tests in a world that
rewards skills and requires them for
middle-class jobs we need to do better
we need to invest in infrastructure or
the economy will fail to grow at its
potential we missed our opportunity to
shorten the recession four years ago by
investing heavily and speedily in
transportation and communications
infrastructure this would have created
millions of jobs in the short term and
laid the foundation for future growth in
the long term we still need these
investments education and infrastructure
are prerequisites for the health and
prosperity of any nation but innovation
the creation of new products and new
industries is the engine that drives
economic growth and innovation depends
upon the continuing advance of science
the congressional majority is eager to
curb the growth in government spending
and reluctant to recognize that
education infrastructure and science are
investments in our future such a
Congress risks America's economic
leadership we need to turn this around
we also need to take a longer-term
perspective on the sustainability of our
largest entitlement programs Medicare
and Social Security in the current
political environment it is almost
impossible to have a rational discussion
of these subjects yet if we fail to curb
the growth of these benefits there will
be over the next three decades a massive
intergenerational transfer of income
from your generation to mine placing
your prosperity at risk and penalizing
generations to come we need to restart
the conversation and develop a humane
fair and sustainable solution and while
we are talking about penalizing future
generations our insufficiently
restrained emission of carbon into the
atmosphere is on track to require the
relocation of coastal populations around
the world and to cause severe drought in
once fertile agricultural region regions
within your lifetimes earlier this month
atmospheric carbon dioxide concentration
exceeded 400 parts per million for the
first time in over three million years
this level is more than forty percent
higher than concentrations prevailing
before the Industrial Revolution began
in the mid 18th century now is the time
for stronger economic incentives
stricter performance standards and large
investments in carbon-free energy
technologies the strategy for such
investments should take full account of
the lessons of the massive 1960s
commitment to space and defense
technology which gave us
high-performance materials computers the
internet and global leadership in
science and technology that propelled
scores of industries and created
millions
jobs the theme that unites all the
elements of the program I'm suggesting
to you is this we need to take the long
view if we fail to invest in education
infrastructure and innovation we short
change the future if we fail to
rationalize entitlements your
generations prosperity will be
jeopardized if we fail to address the
challenges of global warming your
children and your grandchildren will
live in a world burdened by enormous
costs of coping with environmental
disruption and human dislocation in our
current polarized political environment
taking action to ensure the future may
seem almost impossible but I believe you
can make a difference we need fresh
voices at the table and you the best
educated citizens of your generation
need to be among them the powerful
groups that are currently dictating
inaction on government investment
entitlement reform and global warming
are driven by a combination of parochial
short-term self-interest on the one hand
and ideology on the other yet the macro
consequence of these micro motives is
that my generation is attempting to
privilege itself over yours kicking the
can of long-term investment needs and
fiscal and environmental sustainability
down the road no one is openly
advocating taxing your generation to
support hours but this will be the
consequence of our current political
paralysis should it persist you need to
ride to the to the rise to the challenge
speak for yourselves and lead your
generation to a better life it will not
be an easy campaign you will need to
confront strongly entrenched interest
groups on both sides of every issue but
you will find allies
because your aspirations will resonate
with the best instincts of our nation
America has a history of looking to the
future even in the midst of Civil War
President Lincoln opened western lands
or free settlement established the
land-grant colleges authorized the
building of the Transcontinental
Railroad and founded the national
academy of sciences after the Second
World War presidents Truman and
Eisenhower sent War veterans to college
subsidized home ownership built the
nation's highways and invested in
science and technology on an
unprecedented scale what we have done
before as a nation we can do again we
need your engagement your leadership to
make it happen women and men of the yale
college class of 2013
let us go forth to new challenges taking
with us the best of what your four years
and my twenty have taught us follow your
passions and shape lives of personal
fulfillment but listen carefully to what
I say to you on Monday when you graduate
I will then confer upon you the degrees
in Yale College as recommended by the
Dean and admit you to all their rights
and responsibilities take those
responsibilities seriously stand up for
your generation and for those that
follow protect the future from the
parochialism partisanship and paralysis
of the present participate speak up and
lead this nation and the world to the
future you deserve I will be working
alongside you help
congratulations